salut vous l'avez compris aujourd'hui on
va s'intéresser aux légendes du cerveau
pour voir quels étaient leurs petites
bizarreries au delà de leur génie parce
que oui on n'a mis que ces personnes et
elles et ibo cheick du cerveau les kings
de la matière grise les stéphane plaza
de la boîte crânienne
bref qu'ils étaient très intelligents
mais quand on fouille un petit peu on
s'aperçoit qu'ils avaient quand même des
habitudes chez loulou bref c'est
vraiment passionnant et en même temps
tant mieux parce que c'est un champ n'a
pas fait une vidéo
en fait alors c'est parti loïc jeu les
riques je vais donc vous parler d'
exactement six femmes et hommes aussi
excentrique intelligente des noms vous
les connaissez sûrement mais qui dans
leur quotidien ne passait pas toujours
pour des lumières vois ça dépend ce
qu'il vous faut savoir que quand j'ai
fait mes recherches j'ai référence et
une douzaine on va dire de personnalités
intéressantes
donc y'a pas de quoi en faire une série
mais si le concept vous plaît il ya de
quoi faire un épisode de ça dépendra de
vos commentaires et bien sûr du nombre
de vues que fera cette vidéo
[Musique]
alors oui là on est clairement sur un
génie mais si vous vous le connaissez
pour l'invention de l'ampoulé bas il a
fait deux trois autres trucs en fait
déjà il a déposé plus de 1000 brevets
d'invention en 62 ans faut savoir que à
la base de madison était le dernier
enfant d'une fratrie de sept et qu'à
l'âge de 10 ans il s'était construit un
petit labo de chimie dans le sous sol de
sa maison à 10 ans mais à 12 ans il
quitte le sous sol de la maison et y
devient le concessionnaire de la
boutique embarquer dans le train qui
faisait l'aller retour depuis chez lui
jusqu'à detroit il ya quinze ans il
achète une presse d'imprimerie une vrai
qu'il installe dans un wagon à bagages
où il rédige un journal nous crie à bord
ils la prime abord il le distribuer à
bord et le vent à bord c'est le premier
journal qui est édité et distribué dans
un train ensuite il installe son labo de
chimie dans le même wagon à bagages
franchement entre 10 et 15 ans on
faisait quoi nous le gars il y avait
créé un empire
c'est complètement fascinant mais
forcément il ya des limites
dans la foulée il renverse du phosphore
dans le wagon à bagages dans le train ça
fout le feu partout dans tout le train
et du coup il se fait via dans la foulée
il invente un transmetteur receveur pour
le code morse il a alors 19 ans il
aborde aussi un microphone pour les
téléphones le phonographe mais également
la première centrale électrique à
courant continu en gros le mec a monté
un royaume entier avec 35 mille employés
de la fin du 19e au début du xxème dont
l'activité principale était au final
l'électricité mais il n'était pas tout
seul il avait un super employés appelés
nikola tesla tesla il se fait licencier
par edison parce que lui croit que le
courant alternatif et mieux plus
intéressant que qu'on continue et
pourquoi parce que le courant alternatif
on peut le transporter sur de plus
longues distances
comment on fait ça me coûtait je veux le
dire en utilité de transformateurs et
c'est d'ailleurs la technique qu'on
utilise encore aujourd'hui du coup
edison il commence à raconter n'importe
quoi à propos de tesla il raconte l'un
dit aussi sur le courant alternatif et
ils décident pekouz d'électrocuter des
animaux sur la place publique alors ça
c'est pas drôle s'est il fait ça devant
les deux passants pour leur montrer que
olala vous avez vu le courant alternatif
c'est vraiment dangereux faut pas
l'utiliser
et là il se dit et on fabriquait pas une
chaise on mettrait du courant alternatif
dessus comme ça on pourrait électrocuté
des gens pour aller tuer comme ça avec
si tu es tu en penses quoi toi francis
fons et je pense que c'est une bonne
idée et il invente donc la chaise avec
chaise électrique qui fonctionne donc au
courant alternatif
ce qui fout complètement les nerfs un
genre westinghouse qui est le premier
revendeur américain ne croit alternatif
c'est pour lui d'ailleurs que tesla y
travaillent il a même fait des démarches
juridiques pour que l'on dise
westinghouse disait pas si simple plutôt
que l'électrocuter un bon le tribunal
lui donne tort mais parce que je pense
que le juge j'arrivais pas à prononcer
le mot alors c'est quoi le petit détail
croustillant qu'on a sur edison
c'est quoi son petit truc un peu chelou
bah en fait c'est quand il recruter un
nouveau collaborateur pour travailler
avec lui il avait une technique un peu
perso l'invité d'abord à manger chez lui
dans sa maison à lui des élus servir une
soupe sur la table et là il regarde si
le candidat salle et sa soupe avant de
l'avoir goûté à l'or il été recalé
directement par edison parce qu'ils
disent 'on disait qu'il avait fait une
conclusion avant d'avoir fait une
expérience et donc qu'il est si fait ça
avec la soupe
il va faire sa part et au travail c'est
sûr il va [ __ ] ma boîte en l'air donc
il est belle les virer avant même de les
avoir embauché ça se trouve il est
embauché le temps de l'assaut qu'ils
aiment et tenter direct parce que tu as
à l'avant c'est un peu bizarre quand
[Musique]
sarah bernhardt qui était une actrice
française mais c'est surtout la première
star à devenir réellement international
des airs connus du grand public dans le
monde entier et en faisait des tournées
sur tous les continents
allez aussi peut-être la première des
influences
oui monsieur elle avait complètement
compris le pouvoir de la communication
et du marketing au point qu'elle mettait
en scène sa vie et à l'associé son nom a
beaucoup de produits qu'elle recommande
est parce que l les adorer par contre la
rumeur faisait courir le bruit qu'elle
était complètement mythomane le fils
d'alexandre dumas le dira même
publiquement dans une interview et ça
c'est important elle ne supportait pas
les conventions et elle parlait hyper
durement hyper sèchement à tout le monde
instant citation sarah bernhardt aurait
dit il faut haïr très peu car c'est très
fatigant il faut des prises et beaucoup
pardonné souvent mais ne jamais aux
essais à l'époque
bref c'est du clash son comportement
était considéré à l'époque comme
extravagant autre époque autres moeurs
évidemment mais elle avait quand même
quelques habitudes billère chelou quand
même comme un cercueil dans sa chambre
qu'elle emmène avec elle en tournée et
elle dormait dedans et puis aussi elle
voulait se mettre dedans pour apprendre
ses textes
voilà banal quoi
[Musique]
alors lui on le connaît en tant
qu'écrivain mais il était clairement
touche-à-tout tout ce qui concernait le
dessin et l'écriture d'une manière
générale mais aussi il était très connu
pour être une bonne partie qu'ils ne
passaient pas des gens comme ça c'était
le genre un bon gros radin mais vraiment
le bon gros radin alors autant il était
très pauvre début de sa vie autant il
est devenu très vite on va dire
confortable on estime qu'à la fin de sa
vie il avait économisé environ 60
millions d'euros si on convertit sa
fortune à la valeur actuelle
rien que le livre des misérables lui ont
fait gagner 2,5 millions d'euros l'année
de la sortie du roman est d'ailleurs
edmond et jules du concours ou écrit sur
lui l'état fait amusant de gagner 200
mille francs à s'apitoyer sur les terres
du top mais le plus schlusche et victor
hugo c'était sa manière de travailler
quand il voulait écrire il demandait à
son domicile de prendre avec lui avec
d'emmener avec lui où ils voulaient tous
ses vêtements
les vêtements de victor hugo alors je
sais pas s'il veut rester un petit
camion ou pas mais en tout cas ils
veulent tous prendre une fois que le
domestique avait fait ça il rase et
victor hugo enfin le domestique la
majorité de sa barbe et de son crâne
ensuite il se mettait au boulot et quand
on lui a demandé pourquoi il faisait ça
lui il écrivait notre dame de paris à
l'époque tous les disney ça paye
il expliqué que c'était pour être
certain de ne pas pouvoir sortir de chez
lui et de ne pas être distrait par des
métis quand il travaillait en gros comme
il pouvait pas couper les natifs de son
téléphone il s'est dit tiens je vais
être quasiment tout nu et quasiment sans
poils comme ça va vraiment je ne
sortirai pas et je ne serai pas embêté
par des bêtises
[Musique]
même si charles dickens est l'un des
plus grands romanciers de son époque il
n'a pas beaucoup été à l'école et du
coup il s'est auto forme fun fact quand
même c'est lui qui a inventé le concept
du feuilleton en publiant ses oeuvres
par ou une fois par semaine dans les
magazines dans les journaux humour c'est
clairement ce qui fait que aujourd'hui
on a des séries qui existe il était
également hyper engagé il s'attaquait à
l'état lorsque celui-ci supprimer les
aides pour les pauvres ils défendent est
aussi les ouvriers l'éducation pour tous
le droit à une habitation à une hygiène
descendent pour tout le monde et c'est
mehdi keynes avait une habitude chez ebi
parce que sinon j'en parlerai pas dans
cette vidéo
à chaque fois qu'il venait à paris il
allait se promener à la morgue pour
aller voir des piles de corps d un côté
ceux qui n'avaient pas encore été
identifiés et à l'époque c'est pas comme
aujourd'hui on avec on a les empruntons
à l'adn on a plein d'un disque sommes
simplement des photos une dernière
d'idées et donc on peut remonter très
très vite l'identité d'un corps mais à
l'époque il y avait énormément de corps
mutilés ou tués d'inconnus et longtemps
il a caché cette petite habitude ils en
parlaient pas et un jour il a évoqué
dans une interview en disant quand je
suis à paris
les forces invisibles mais traîne
jusqu'à la mort je veux pas y aller mais
je continue à le faire
autre petite bizarrerie il avait un
régime alimentaire très particulier à
base de champagne mais recommandations
du médecin
donc c'était que de tous à base de
champagne voilà
[Musique]
alors monsieur ford
l'homme qui dans les années 30 sais pas
si vous vous rendez compte fournissez un
tiers des voitures dans le monde
faire que tu prenais trois personnes y
en avait au moins un quart et une ford
ou qui la disent depuis l'âge de 12 ans
le gars démonter remontent des trucs
comme des montres des moteurs etc et à
15 ans il construit tout seul une
machine à vapeur
c'est comme son pote edison e à 15 ans
ils font des trucs de ouf
ensuite il a largement participé à la
mise en place de la production de masse
au début du 20e siècle ce qui lui a fait
atteindre le haut du classement des
personnes les plus riches du monde et à
côté pour le récompenser de tout ce qui
fait il reçoit en 1938 la grande croix
de l'ordre de l'aigle allemand un pied
la décoration offerte aux étrangers par
par les nazis donc alors lui il dira
publiquement expliquera dans les
interviews que bon bah euh c'est du
business c'est comme ça ça veut rien
dire mais un grand nombre de ces
déclarations orales ou dans ses livres
démontre largement qu'il était
clairement antisémite
la question est est-ce qu'il ya un autre
truc chelou sur lui un bon bah ça
c'était déjà bien celle où mais oui il
ya autre chose
henry ford avec comme comme habitude
quand il marchait chez lui dans sa
propriété d'attaché toutes les mauvaises
herbes qui croisait sur ce ton chemin
toutes les plantes etc
il est mangée en reçoit en en faisant
des salades sans les mettant directement
sur du pain sont directement dans sa
bouche parce que lui avait une théorie
disait que le corps humain c'était une
machine et que donc comme si une machine
comme une voiture
il faut lui donner du carburant et comme
cette machine vient de la terre il faut
que le carburant soit des choses qui
viennent directement de la terre voilà
c'est chez nous parce que vraiment il
aurait aussi pu manger des pommes de
terre sainte mais non les mauvaises
herbes de s'approprier
[Musique]
nous parlons ici du père fondateur de la
théorie de la sélection naturelle qui
fait elle même partie de la théorie de
l'évolution des espèces
souvent on dit darwin c'est l'évolution
des espèces non c'est la sélection
naturelle qui est une des théories qui
fait partie de la plus grosse tête en
gros ce que ça veut dire c'est que pour
darwin les animaux et les végétaux
doivent s'adapter pour survivre et seuls
ceux qui survivent et bien transmettre
leurs gènes peuvent donc se reproduire
et c'est ainsi que les humains ont pu
voir le jour
alors c'est extrêmement résumé je le
sais mais c'est ça et oui je vous lis
dans les commentaires il y en a certains
qui contredit cette théorie c'est vrai
et leur meilleur argument c'est
l'absence de chaînon manquant on n'a pas
trouvé le chaînon manquant qui relierait
le singe et l'être humain je vais pas
vous faire un topo complet sur darwin
mais plutôt parler de cette habitude
chelou qu'il avait et qui n'est pas très
connu notre charles faisait partie de la
chine clab littéralement le club des
gouttes ont alors c'est un petit club
sans pathos on sera content on se
retrouve éjecté ans raconte les uns les
autres ce qu'on a mangé de nouveau dans
notre jeu et lui il en avait des choses
à raconter darwin basque durant ces cinq
ans d'expéditions à bord du beagle où il
visite une grande partie du monde
et à chaque fois il passe la majeure
partie de son temps à terre je crois que
c'est plus de deux tiers de son temps
pour observer et récolter des infos et
surtout bien manger bah oui darwin a
voulu manger
écoutez moi bien tous les animaux est à
sec qu'il a rencontré lors de son voyage
terre du tattoo à l'araignée en passant
aussi bête puma il a tout bouffé alors
autant vous dire qu'ils devaient pas
avoir l'air ouf le mec qui passait juste
après darwin là au club des boutons pour
dire voilà bah merci charles
moi j'ai mangé une truite est bien alors
évidemment il ya d'autres trucs chelous
chez pas mal d'autres personnes certains
pourraient faire l'objet donc je vous le
disais tout à l'heure d'une deuxième et
dernière vidéo pour boucler ça ça ça va
dépendre de ce que vous me dites dans
les commentaires mais il y en a d'autres
alors c'est pas des trucs assez costaud
pour traiter ça sur une vidéo complète
du coup attention je voulais raconter
dans les fun fact quotidienne que je
fais sur instagram aujourd'hui ou demain
et je sais
je sais que certains sont en train de
faire une crise d'urticaire quand je dis
ça mais juste alors mais déjà calmez
vous parce que ça va aller et c'est pas
grave c'est pas important
c'est justement en vrai des petits trucs
en plus que je peux pas mettre dans une
vidéo c'est pas assez intéressant ça
mérite pas mais si vous n'aimez pas à ta
g c'est pas grave du tout du tout pas
grave si vous voyez pas ça et puis aussi
c'est que j'ai une vie sur les autres
réseaux sociaux où je fais d'autres
contenus et ça c'est pas d'aujourd'hui
donc voilà rien de grave
rationnel si vous ne connaissez pas je
m'appelle toujours fabien olicard vous
pouvez vous abonner à la chaîne c'est
gratuit vous pouvez activer la cloche
pour être sûr de voir les prochaines
vidéo leakée cette vidéo si elle vous a
plu et ici je vous mets deux autres
vidéos qui peuvent vous intéresser
une vidéo sur des légendes urbaines sur
picasso einstein son chauffeur qui sont
justes ouf
et une vidéo sur dix idées reçues qui
existent sur le cerveau à très bientôt
ciao